donc bon soir comme bertrand l'a signalé
je suis
dix ans aux beaux-arts de nîmes j'arrive
en fin de cursus
et je vais vous présenter un petit
extrait du mémoire que je suis en train
de préparer qui pour l'instant n'a pas
son titre définitif qui s'appelle
représentation du travail dans le champ
de l'art contemporain
donc ce qui m'intéresse c'est la même
manière que ce que vient de dire chaplin
ici c'est apparemment s'adapter de 1940
donc c'est pas tout jeune c'est que
cette citation qui nous fait ici et je
la trouve finalement aussi belle qu'elle
est effrayante
étant donné qu'elle est brûlante de par
son actualité et si je choisis ce sujet
du travail à l'intérieur de mon travail
c'est justement parce que moi même je
suis issu de ce travail ouvrier
je suis moi même fils d'ouvrier ma mère
travaille l usine depuis plus de 30 ans
je crois maintenant
donc il ya un passage je sais pas si
vous avez eu l'occasion de le re
visionner récemment dans l'autre film de
chaplin qui s'appelle les temps modernes
qui a donné son titre d'ailleurs à la
conférence où on voit chaplin s'activer
sur sa ligne de production et être
complètement dépassés par la vitesse et
finalement toutes ces histoires sur la
technologie et le progrès qui était
censé nous apporter le bonheur en 2019
on fait les comptes et on s'aperçoit
qu'on n'est pas spécialement plus
avancés que dans les années 40
malheureusement on n'est pas plus
heureux il ya plus hitler mais il ya des
nouveaux challengers qui sont en place
un peu partout dans le monde entier et
c'est pas très rassurant pour la suite
donc voilà je mets un moment assez
important avant de commencer à vraiment
m'intéresser au travail donc au sens de
travailler lusine parce que en
rejoignant les beaux-arts jeu je fais ce
travail dans mon cerveau qui a un
travail plus ou moins conscient à ce
moment là de me mettrai en rupture de
distinguer ma vie d'avant celle
d'ouvriers d'intérimaires et de me
projeter vers la suite qui s'annonce
plus radieuse donc écoles supérieures
émancipation de la classe ouvrière
je vais je vais atterrir enfin je vais
changer ma condition évoluer avoir un
choisir mon destin en quelque sorte
et du coup à la je fais se distingue au
départ parce que je pense que quelque
part je n'assume pas le fait que je
vienne de ce milieu prolos laborieux etc
et je souhaite à tout prix oublier ça et
me concentrer uniquement sur l'avenir
mais par la force des choses là j'arrive
à la fin de mes études
ça me revient un petit peu en pleine
poire je me dis je ne peux pas avancer
en rognant tout ce que j'ai pu être
avant ça serait insulté ma mère mon père
ainsi que ma famille proche qui s'est
sacrifié finalement en quelque sorte
sans le savoir pour me permettre à moi
d'accéder à ce niveau supérieur qui est
celui des études les beaux-arts qui
puisait est ce que je trouvais
intéressant justement c'était le fait
que pour qui n'a jamais mis les pieds en
usine ou dans une école d'art ce sont
des concepts assez abstrait on a bombé
là par exemple avec les temps modernes
de chaplin une imagerie qui s'active un
fantasme un peu de lusine mais on ne
pourra jamais ressentir dans sa chair
dans son corps ce que c'est que vivre ça
et du coup tout mon travail qui est un
petit peu au ralenti à ce moment là je
découvre ce nouveau monde des beaux-arts
avec tout d'un coup un accès à la
culture à la philosophie j'ai étais
jamais allé dans un musée avant enfin
jeudi à terry vraiment au départ par
hasard je connais vite fait dali picasso
les grands noms comme ça mais je les
rejoins parce que j'ai besoin de
m'exprimer et je me dis bon bcsa comme
serait peut être par exemple le sport ou
autre chose
et j'y arrive je suis admis et du coup
tout mon travail consiste à trouver des
formes à cette réflexion que j'ai autour
du travail justement et je mets donc je
j'accumule des connaissances des
connaissances que je vais mettre au
service
de ce monde qui est un monde à mon sens
invisible et je vais écrire donc là
c'était tout récent je vais vous citer
un peut-être un court passage pour vous
montrer un petit peu de quoi il en
retourne j'ai eu la chance de travailler
avec une cinéaste est une artiste qui
s'appelle véronique aubouy qui fait
beaucoup de documentaires d'ailleurs et
qui s'intéresse tout particulièrement
aux cartographies donc immédiatement ça
me fait tilt et je me mets à écrire une
sorte de pièce si vous voulez qu'ils
s'appellent les témoins de lusine
invisible et cette pièce là le moyen que
j'ai de la mettre en oeuvre donc c'est
le moyen de la performance et je vais
pour une fois moi qui me sert
allègrement dans tout ce que j'ai vécu
dans tout ce que j'ai vu à l' usine qui
m'a choqué qui m'a donné envie justement
d'en sortir je voulais pas que mon
avenir ressemble à ces quelques mois que
je passais chaque été à travailler un
coup avec ma mère un coup à amazon
si j'ai un peu de temps je vous parlerai
d'amazon parce que c'est c'est bien
garni je crois que c'est le meilleur job
que j'ai fait de ma vie c'était l'enfer
je me suis demandé qu'est ce que j'avais
fait pour mériter ça et du coup je mets
je moi qui m'étais servi dans tout cet
univers de lusine cet univers qu'on ne
connaît pas et que j'avais pu voir et
ressentir dans mon corps j'appelle ma
mère et je lui demande si ça n'intéresse
de participer à l'une de mes
performances je l'invite pour une fois
c'est elle qui va venir sur mon
territoire
donc il faut savoir que ma mère qui est
l usine l'art c'est une idée enfin c'est
très très très abstrait et elle fait
donc par pur amour et confiance
maternelle qu'elle m'accorde
elle me fait la promesse de participer
de là je vais écrire un texte et par
visioconférence donc avec un écran comme
ici on va dire ce texte ensemble et je
vais vous en citer un petit passage
à l'intérieur on vient à bout d'une
palette que déjà la suivante identique
prend sa place on répète la même
opération la même chorégraphie le même
objet le monde nous le monde autour de
nous s'activent bougent et tout nous est
égal tout est condamné à reprendre
inexorablement sa place c'est le
caractère infini et quelque part
prédéfinis des schémas cycliques propres
à cet environnement si bien que les
effets produits tendent à faire
disparaître lusine sur elle même on ne
distingue plus rien le rapport au temps
s'est estompé et seule la fatigue permet
encore d'accrocher le réel lusine conti
lusine constituer un territoire
autarcique un système indépendant et
autonome elle n'existe que pour
elle-même sans se soucier de
l'environnement qu'elle habite lusine
est invisible hors du temps hors du
monde dans son temps dans son monde
l'usiné est invisible ces quelques
témoins disparaissent chaque matin dans
son ventre dans leur coin et ce qui
m'avait touché en fait dans ce que
j'avais pu voir dans ce les gens que
j'avais pu rencontrer dans ce milieu là
c'est que donc aucun vous l'imaginez
bien qu'aucun et là par choix
tous y sont par défaut par dépit par
découragement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu la chance ou
l'envi de poursuivre des études et
d'aspirer à mieux c'était le cas de ma
mère d'ailleurs qui a dû rester pour
s'occuper de sa mère à elle qui était
malade et qui du coup quelque part a dû
sacrifier une partie de ses rêves et de
ses désirs qui étaient des désirs quand
elle m'en parlait qu'ils étaient tous
tout relatif un rien d'exceptionnel rien
d'extraordinaire mais lorsqu'on grandit
dans ces milieux là on apprend à rêvez
pas trop grand on grandit avec cet adage
qui dit dans la vie on fait ce qu'on
peut
parce qu'on veut on finit par se
persuader que c'est vrai moi j'ai réussi
quelque part je suis en train je suis en
cours
de déjouer sa est en fait tout ce
travail que j'accomplis qui parle d'elle
qui parle du milieu dans lequel elle
travaille c'est un moyen aussi pour moi
de lui rendre hommage rendre hommage à
toutes ces personnes qu'on ne voit pas
et qui font que ce monde tourne plus ou
moins bien économiquement ça va parce
que lorsqu'on se rend dans ses magasins
tous ces objets il a bien fallu les
conditionner les emballer et c'est des
gens qui sont derrière tout notre
confort actuel le travail le plus
important que j'ai fait pour justement
me réconcilier quelque part avec la
classe dont je venais c'était un autre
travail d'écriture l'écriture revenait
sans cesse c'était pour moi comme un
socle pour une sculpture ou à chaque
fois je pouvais revenir sur ce socle là
ça me permettait d'improviser d'imaginer
des formes donc par la sculpture
l'installation la photographie la vidéo
je suis assez pluridisciplinaire j'ai
une idée je l'écris et à partir de ce
que j'ai écrit je vais essayer d'en
ressortir une forme plastique artistique
dans la mesure du possible intéressante
et du coup je suis tellement là c'est
parce que pendant que c'est aux
beaux-arts en même temps chaque été je
continue d'aller à l'usiné travaille
avec elle et je la vois et je vois tous
ces gens qui ont tous le même discours
peu n'importe quelle usine dans laquelle
je travaille que ce soit chez amazon
wurtz avec ma mère ou dans votre boîte
j'entends tout le temps les mêmes choses
si j'avais pu si j'avais su la chance
continue continue reste pas là ne perds
pas ton temps avance des jeunes tel
temps enfin de tenter repas ici au bout
d'un moment il ya une espèce de
ras-le-bol et je vais mettre à
écrire un vrai texte pour une fois ce
n'était pas juste un texte qui
accompagne et une vidéo une performance
un grand texte qui doit faire à peu près
je les ai dit et il fait à peu près 60
pages je crois que j'ai appelé 4h13 13
heures pile
c'était la fourchette dans laquelle je
travaillais avec ma mère le matin quand
on fait les trois huit
comme ça donc c'était je mettais mon
réveil exprès à 4,13 à 4h13 parce que je
savais qu'elle se lever à 4 heures du
matin pile et du coup je me disais des
gens attendent et je me disais bon il me
reste encore 13 minutes pour ne pas trop
y penser pour me persuader quand on veut
pas y aller ça me fait flipper j'ai pas
envie d'y aller c'est horrible et tout
est du coup ce texte là je l'écris et je
vais raconter le quotidien je vais
raconter une journée donc je vais
raconter 8h et ses huit heures ce sont
des ces huit heures qui sont étirable
c'est à dire que je raconte une journée
mais finalement vu que c'est sans cesse
la même qui se répètent ces gens
racontent toutes les anecdotes toutes
les choses qu'on tous les chemins qu'on
emprunte pour éviter le travail pour se
cacher en stage pour aller fumer des
cigarettes
on doit demander la permission pour
aller pisser vous imaginez bien que si
vous êtes sur une ligne de production et
vous barrer au milieu ça fout tout en
l'air derrière donc du coup vous êtes
tout le temps contre un dans le corps
dans l'esprit et au bout d'un moment
vous posez votre cerveau à l'entrée et
parfois il y en a certains qui au bout
d'un certain temps finissent par
l'oublier
là où ils ont laissé ils sont
complètement aliénés
en fait c'est le principe même de la
nation votre corps devient une sorte de
marchandises et du coup je vais conclure
par un extrait de ce texte dont je suis
en train de vous parler un court passage
qui se situe vers la fin et ensuite je
pense je sais pas depuis combien de
temps je parle autant je parle depuis
longtemps
donc s'il était là les ouvriers avec qui
travaille ma mère c'était bien souvent
par défaut par dépit par nonce mans
parce que j'entendais regret un peu
d'amertume et beaucoup de fatigue
ma mère elle n'avait pas choisi elle
aurait aimé faire barmaid fleuriste ou
tenir une quincaillerie
rien d'extravagant rien d'impossible à
mon sens mais quand ma grand mère tomba
malade il fallait bien quelqu'un pour
s'en occuper
à cette époque là mon grand-père
balbutier difficilement ses premiers
mots en français et enchaîner deux
boulots pour subvenir aux besoins
médicaux de sa femme ainsi qu'aux
besoins de son foyer
ma ma mère étant l'aîné a donc tiré une
croix sur une partie de sa jeunesse de
ses envies de ses rêves aussi j'imagine
pour s'occuper pleinement de ma
grand-mère et permettre à son petit
frère de suivre sa route vers paris
sans se retourner un sacrifice en somme
un sacrifice pour ce qu'elle aime et
chéri le plus tant le plus tendrement du
monde
un sacrifice pour nous pour qu'on aille
de l'avant pour qu'on réussisse une vie
discrète par procuration une vie banale
est exceptionnel or jean ordinaire et
hors du commun
c'est à des degrés différents l'histoire
de la plupart des personnes que j'ai
rencontrés là-bas
l'histoire des personnes sans histoire
qui se sont sacrifiés pour leurs proches
pour leur enfant pour l'avenir de leurs
enfants dehors en dehors très loin des
grands murs en taule jonché de porte
rouge écarlate et de grandes barres
métalliques jaune la façade gris dans la
façade grise en principe de l' usine
spécialisée dans le packaging
l'emballage de produits de luxe
cosmétique pharmaceutique alcool et
cigarettes
voilà pour ce qui est de mon passage
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté jusqu'au
bout
et
[Applaudissements]